طيب افتكرت انه هذا الحرف الذي تعمل عليه
الان وحرف عربي ولكن له ايضا ذاكره مختلفه
عن اللغه عن الشكل الذي وصل اليه
بحثت في هذا المطرح انه ذهبت الى مصدر هذا
الحرف في في ذاكرته في تاريخه بالطبيعه
الحال اشتغلت كثير على هالموضوع لكن يعني
كلغه العربيه انحدرت من الاراميه اللغه
الام
فهناك تناسب بعض اشكال الحروف في
[موسيقى]
ناسيه يعني بتكوين تكوين اخر الى لكن لنكن
واضحين يعني اكثر بالفتره العباسيه اللي
جرى فيها تقعيض الحرف وتثبيت اشكال الحروف
ان كان اهم مخاض يعني
لهندسه الحرف
وتحويله الى لغه فعلا اكاديميه وصوتيا
يعني مثلا اذا دخلنا بتكوين حرف اللي
اخذناه الباء مر بعده مخابرات واشكال لحتى
وحتى حتى وجدت شيفره ناظمه لكل هذا الشيء
لكن مثل ما حكيت القصه هي بعهد الخطاط
الشهيره ابن مقلى او الخلق الخطاط والباحث
والشاعر والموسيقي ابن مقلى هو اوجد اول
منظومه اللي هي الخط المنسوب فنسب الحروف
الى دائره ووضع الالف هي قطر الدائره اللي
هي الانسان بطوله الكامل يعني هي مقاربه
مع الانسان اللي شغل عليه ليوناردو دافنشي
في الانسان الرجل
فالمخمس
بابعاد الخمسه
[موسيقى]
هي قطر الدائره وبطول سبع نقاط وعند
الانسان
هو سبعه رؤوس فما معنى النقطه هي الراس
سابق نعم عملت دراسه امانه عن هذا الموضوع
هي مقارنه بين الاثنين لكن هي هواجس تنتاب
كل العالم اذا كانت الالف هلا صار انا
عندي رغبه انا اعرف اذا كانت الالف في قطر
الدائره ماذا عن بقيه الحروف يعني تاخذ
اجزاء من الدائره اجزاء من الدائره فيقول
يكون في بعض الحروف مثل التاليه يسمى حرف
منكب في حرف مستلقي في حرف راجع في حرف
مضطجع فيعني
تتكلم عن هيئات الحروف يعني يعني مثلا انا
اردت حرف جيم
كما يقول النفري والحرف يسري حيث القصد
جيم جنه جيم جحيم او جيم جهنم بمعنى ممكن
تاخذه الى الاقصى الى من الاقصى الى
الاقصى فيوجد نقضين يعني
هذا الشخص ايضا هو يعلم في الموسيقى
وشاعر هو شاعر كونه شاعر موسيقي يعني فينا
نقول هو انجز معرفه كامله او ابتكر او ثبت
شكل الحرف كما ان يكون واضاف الكثير اضاف
الكثير حتى باطلاع الواسع على علم الفلك
يعني فلكي هنا فساهم ايضا
باسقاطات عجيبه عن الحرف والنجوم والحرف
والسماء والكواكب فكان بحث عميق جدا يعني
بدنا بالنتيجه يعني اوصل للحرف الى مفهوم
مفهوم كوني وليس مفهوم فقط
مرتبط
بشيء مادي او شيء موسيقي